hello everybody and welcome to part 18
of let's play from dust okay ah this
island has been kicking my ass and more
than you've been able to see I've ivory
recorded this part more times than I'd
like to admit just because I've died so
many times and it's it's it's kind of
ridiculous but my brother was finally
kind enough to help explain why I was
failing so hardcore and also teach me a
few new tricks um I didn't know that you
could dump all this water at once you
could dump anything you're holding just
at once it must have been in a tip a
long time ago I didn't know about it I'm
an idiot
basically that's what I'm trying to say
so what's going on now he also told me
that um even if it looks bleak I might
as well just keep going because
eventually the lava that pours in from
the walls will stop which I it continued
for so long I never thought it would so
eventually it will stop apparently so
but I'm gonna keep going continuing this
way in this regards because I need to
get this totem then this totem so that I
can control the water and only the water
which is what I really need to control
in the first place and then get on this
thing right here so once I do that then
I'll be golden and then I'll finally be
able to get out of this place but I just
I just apparently have been going out
about it the wrong way which is fine I
suppose
I should have done it better a long time
ago let's see what you guys going
probably not probably not gonna have
enough time no knots and Santa always
wants to get in the party or earth
rather dirt okay dump it all at once
learning learning dump dump yeah that
that's much faster I I really would have
liked to have known about that a long
time ago dumb not Sam nots and why does
sand always want to play when it is not
welcome all right okay that's happening
Oh get out of here lava man that is a
lot of love
I mean wow look at that that is
ridiculous
how much that's covering everything I
gotta get in a channel so that it
doesn't get in the way of me trying to
get to that anti llama
cuz that's what's really important the
anti lava is like the most important
thing I get here so I need to send
someone to get to it right away
go man go yes right through the lava
that's perfect
couldn't be smarter oh don't don't don't
talk to me like that don't back sass me
alright yeah I'm picking up the entire
lava flow for you you're welcome buddy
now don't die don't die that's the only
requirement oh no oh you died oh you son
of a [ __ ] you son of a [ __ ] I hate you
oh this volcano it's ridiculous look at
this thing just get out of here oh we
also my brother also informed me that I
can just pick up the dirt from these
islands so they don't die which has
plagued me for the entire game just
can't people constantly just dying
alright that guy's a trooper he's gonna
make it
maybe probably not what do I know I save
you sings and then they do not happen Oh
get out of there get out of there
stop with the lava stop with the lava
seriously stop with the lava getting
pretty tired of this yeah you're gonna
build up and it's gonna immediately
catch on fire I just I'm predicting this
at the sand everywhere oh god get away
get away get away get the sand out of
here oh man so glad my brother taught me
about that because that would be dead
right now yes it would be very dead okay
how's my guy doing on that anti lava
machine there he goes finally get back
there get back there
now once I get that then it's pretty
much gravy from then on out because I'm
able
oh I need to evaporate
because then I'm able to finally get to
these these statues but after I wait
everything out it's raining all nothing
compared to my evaporation
okay thank goodness lava has finally
slowed down
but not enough and still it's still at
the [ __ ] you markiplier levels I needed
to go lower than that
whatever alright okay
so we're finally learning about the
secrets dump all in one glob
Laure yep just like that okay that guy's
passing on the secret over there all
right we're almost getting to a point
where we're not gonna kill everyone
which is good very good and this is
finally starting to get under control
but huh things are going too well I
imagine it's about time for the walls to
start pouring lava out at everyone that
seems about right
yep it seems to calm too nice I shoulda
keep like this oh I see this no way no
way
you're not surrounding my village with
vegetation so that you can just catch on
fire no I refuse
okay now that village is finally
protected now we can move forward
maybe maybe probably not all right let's
try to populate this one go go man go
you too man not really cuz you're all
better dad I bet I just been yeah oh I
doesn't sound good Oh No
get out of there what do you think
you're doing I built up a freakin wall a
huge wall you all saw oh come on get out
of here get out of here get out of here
good things rappelling freakin lava
actually as soon as this gets built I'm
gonna move it okay bang your gums get
your thing and you are moving all the
entire volcano is awakening okay you're
all boned you're all boned cuz I'll move
this move it move it move it move it
move it here get here just go there up
now it's too late too late you're all
boned Oh f man Oh F get out of here get
out of here oh no no no no no no Oh F F
F F F F F M huh Oh yep Oh get the secret
there get the secret there now buddy now
friend oh you got to get it I can only
buy you so much time cuz the lava is
kind of like all up in your grill oh boy
oh boy okay
oh did you get it oh you got it wow you
got it I can't believe you got it they
have the secret now of repelled lava Wow
wowie wow wow
they did it while they did it are you
still moving your totem guys move your
totem all right helping you I'm helping
you don't worry I'm helping you okay so
as soon as they move it there hopefully
we'll just be able to be repelled and
then any time it rains it'll kind of
cool off the area and I can just pick it
back up again hopefully that's hopefully
how it works and may not be actually how
it works
all right whatever whatever I'm actually
making progress doing more than I've
ever done before which is saying
something okay
yeah okay then that moved and then now
get rid of all the dirt because no
vegetation I refuse to allow vegetation
it's raining beware of floods okay I get
that and you guys are screwed over there
okay evaporate water just until it stops
raining
oh I think I'm actually gonna do this I
may actually do this guys get out
don't kill my guys do not kill do not no
no no no yo yo yo that's right
Oh what the hell happened there oh thank
you so much for creating a chasm all
right all right that's enough
evaporation now get people here get
people there just get people there I'll
protect them maybe probably not but I'll
try I'll try to protect you guys
oh no no no nope nope nope nope nope no
no no no no okay that's the last one
that's the last totem if I can get that
totem then who knows maybe I'll actually
win this
but then again probably not this thing
never go my way in this game it just
keeps kicking me while I'm down beating
me until I'm just a bloody pulp and I
can't even see a balls
okay maybe maybe I can get this I was
told that at some point this lava flow
would stop now I don't see that
happening maybe I can just sort it box
it up so it flows out words not in words
would be nice okay okay oh I'm getting
just enough time where that's working
who's who's screaming whoo screaming
don't scream stop screaming
okay no vegetation for you
get out of here vegetation nope no
vegetation I realize this get out of
here no vegetation no vegetation I
refuse get them the power of lava
repelled lava Oh No
oh my goodness aw screw it they're
portals open portals open get people
there Oh amplify the breath get out of
here out of here out of here out of here
out of here get oh get out of here no
I'm so close I'm so close
get out of here I'm so close I'm so
close I'm so close
two more people one more people okay I'm
better I guess I did it get gimme gimme
gimme gimme gimme gimme out of here out
of here oh yeah yes yeah oh yeah Oh
who's the best oh I did it oh you do not
know how much that island has been
kicking my ass and I did it
Oh Oh so happy I'm so happy I'm happy
I'm a tiger
oh yeah ah okay all right oh man oh this
does not look good
dandy see Nikita oh man did I ki where
it all began there's nothing here my lad
me anodized Armani oh boy oh yeah he
paddock a column no kidding he's not
even a totem now lose a Manny Manny
caulk mushy Dava oh that's good Geoff's
Arachne Anita a Yankee taco Zatanna okay
man seriously no kidding I have been
wiped out in that last level at least 20
times that you have not seen and I wish
I kept all the recordings because then
you would have seen a
mail compilation but I have to cut it
here so thank you guys so much for
watching and I'm glad I didn't have to
make you put up with me failing each and
every time but it was finally worth it
it finally paid off so thank you guys so
much for watching and I will see you
guys in part 19 of let's play from dust
bye bye